what what's been going on with that
because I've seen a lot of activity on
social media with the hashtag freebam
and people seem to think that you're the
Britney Spears of Jackass the evil
villains have taken over your life and
stolen all your money and like can we
safely say that none of that is true I I
don't know what's been going on because
I haven't been able to look as a matter
of fact I can't even post on my
Instagram everything has to go for
Johnny Schiller from heart Supply
because I design a contract because when
I was dealing with the lawsuit with
Paramount and jackass I was posted like
[ __ ] these [ __ ] potentially
ruining my lawsuit so I had a sign of
paper saying that only Johnny can clear
what goes through my Instagram so I
don't even know my new passcode I can't
control what goes on it can I tell you I
think that's good news
like you dude and I I couldn't be
trusted with the laptop computer until I
had been completely sober for nine
months and even then it was a little bit
questionable so yeah I think that having
that filter you know I think I I think
that's absolutely great news and I hope
to because I think that that looking at
your social media since you got out of
treatment it's feeling a lot more like
you when you're in treatment it didn't
it was [ __ ] obvious that that was not
bam posting it was not in your voice it
it was like oddly like sort of
masquerading as you but it wasn't you
and it seemed kind of ingenuine and it's
starting to feel more genuine so I get
the sense that you're participating in
what goes out yeah I I I still haven't
looked to see what has happened but now
that I have my phone back I just shoot
photos send it to Schiller often if he
likes it or whatever then he'll post it
that's what I mean yeah that's good
because dude it's it's tough to see some
of that [ __ ] [ __ ] that you were
posting man
well at the time I just figured
Instagram should be real because
everybody's posted stuff like at the
beach when my buddy's having a blast at
the blah blah having a blast I'm like
why can't it be like this [ __ ] back
did to me and I'm having a [ __ ] day you
know like like that's why you know if
I'm having a problem I'm gonna post it
you know like and and I guess that's not
the case because it's like Bam's at it
again you know yeah the problem is that
it was very real and what was real was
that you were having a [ __ ] meltdown
you know like you could have used a
little bit of uh less real yeah
maybe he'll post at the beach would have
done nice right
at the beach with your buddies
you said that that you haven't been able
to see any of the stuff that's been
going on on social media and I think
that that's probably a blessing I gotta
[ __ ] what goes on on social media
there's nothing that we need to see
there but from your perspective of what
you have seen and what your experience
has been over the last year can we
safely say that you have not been a
prisoner and mistreated and like you
know like stolen from like like the the
whole like help us understand your
situation no I I've I was just getting
treatment for my alcohol and bipolar and
um
and I I just did more time than I was
supposed to just from getting kicked out
for dumb reasons but
um now I'm I'm out I get freedom I get a
phone and uh nobody was forcing me to be
there and um there's this really crazy
lady that I know who has been like
posting my Guardians number on my aunt
missing Nick Don Pierre's proxy and like
has just been on a
prowl just making up so many lives she
has now has a lawsuit by five different
people that are my friends or family
that and I think she's even a [ __ ]
lawyer or something but but that's why
she can get the dirt of everything she
has footage of me barfing in the back in
the police car she has footage of me
getting handcuffed out of this nice
hotel in in Madero Beach when when I had
a I was going to surprise Nikki and
Phoenix at a joint room at the top Suite
until I forget what his name was but as
soon as I went in to surprise knock him
and surprise him the cops were already
there to arrest me and I was on a couple
white claws I wasn't out of control but
they handcuffed me and said you're
getting Baker acted for saying you're
going to jump off a bridge or whatever
I'm like oh my God I can relate what's a
Baker Act is just Florida's version of a
5150 yeah same exact thing and yeah
sorry so Steve the Britney Spears thing
like that was a conservatorship and this
is different right Britney Spears had a
conservatorship which has financial
implications in which like she had no
control of her own money and other
people could spend their own money and
despite like people conspiracy theorists
online trying to say that that a
guardianship is the same as a
conservatorship it's not and nobody has
taken control of your money bam can we
confirm that
yeah absolutely my dad is my accountant
and it goes nowhere else but his his
pockets
that can help shut up a lot of noise
that is very counter productive and very
destructive and just [ __ ] and thank
you for clearing that up and if I hear
you correctly what's happened over the
last year is that you've gotten help
which you acknowledge that you need
yeah
yeah get a chance the good news is
like if my dad was to rip me off he
doesn't like sports cars or fancy cars
he's too fat to fit in a Ferrari all he
likes is cheesesteaks and hoagies and
Elvis memorabilia which he already has
all of it I don't think there's anything
left that he doesn't have so he doesn't
[ __ ] want anything so okay if he's
gonna rip me off go ahead like you know
like he's he's the perfect person to
handle my money because he's just not
the type of person that needs Prada
shoes and [ __ ] even though he doesn't
care definitely loves you too it's
called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're at ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
foreign